foreign
a couple of months ago we did a huge
millions and millions of people watched
uh live stream for free called the real
estate reality check we addressed
several things in that hour and we don't
have time to address them all right now
but a lot of people were predicting 2008
again that real estate prices were going
to absolutely tank we said they are not
going to tank because there is a pool of
buyers that is much larger than the pool
of sellers still and the supply demand
curve will maintain the prices meaning
when you have a whole bunch of people
trying to buy a few things it holds
prices up
it's that simple when there's a scarcity
prices go up or at least are maintained
at a minimum and we said of course the
exception to that
is the areas where people are leaving in
mass and we showed a map of the number
of people that have left New York and
left California and have left some of
the high crime cities
and crazy
politics of all kinds defund the police
or whatever else cities and so uh and we
said the so far though even those areas
California New York Seattle Portland
have not seen decreases in real estate
values that was about two months ago
three months ago reports are coming out
right now we just got one dropped on the
desk Western U.S continues to lead in
home price declines so now California is
seeing the mass Exodus of California
starting to affect pricing there in some
of the areas San Francisco's taking some
real hits 3.4 percent of the top hundred
cities the city that has taken the
largest drop in price declines so far as
Seattle high crime situation with the
anarchists taking down the entire
downtown area and it made it impossible
to function economically in that
beautiful downtown area of Seattle it's
a gorgeous City or it was was and um
the lack of Law and Order always screws
up economics when you can't operate
because people steal all your stuff or
burn it it's very difficult to run a
business it's kind of basic you know
Common Sense stuff and so these areas
are getting hammered uh their home
appreciation values dropping like crazy
meantime Louisville Birmingham Southern
cities in Texas Southeast are going up
in value
during the time some of you predicted
that Dave Ramsey this isn't going to age
well it's going to be 2008 again the
entire thing is going to crash I kept
telling you now here's the numbers it's
not going to crash and so we're here to
tell you the numbers are coming out and
we told you so yeah this is real data
and we use data last time too and we're
just using the newest data that's
showing that it's a it's a different
time and it's not all down some areas
are going up some areas are going down
and there are winners and losers in
other article States and yes those that
got houses when the interest rates were
super low are cheering for themselves
but those that want to get into a house
it's not too late for you either because
the competition is slowed down well
here's what prices are we have this huge
increase in 20. the record house price
increase in 21 you know 18 up right 29
up in 20. and then we said you know 22
is going to be seven or eight percent up
which appears to be holding nationally
now locally we've had some areas that
are down five percent or down 10 percent
uh we've got other areas that are up
five percent but it seems to be that
we're going to be in the five to seven
percent by year end that prediction was
made by other people but the data that
we had seemed to support it and we went
with that and it looks like that's going
to be about true in 2023 we said it's
going to return to normal price
increases in homes of two to five
percent and the data is still indicating
that that's what's going to happen all
of this to say that
you're watching the news and you know
the inflation is horrible the worst
inflationary economy in 40 years right
now
and you're going to the polls in a week
or you're going to the polls right I'm
going today to early vote make sure I
you know do what I can to correct this
um you're fired that's the message and
so um
you know you can't you can't run
something you get you don't get to run
it anymore that includes the country
okay but the um anyway the uh uh all of
that aside the the the thing that's
happening with real estate is interest
rates have gone way up there on bumping
up close to seven percent now on a
30-year fixed uh up from the threes and
you know seven percent and the scope of
a life as long as mine is very low
I remember lots of years selling real
estate 11 12 10 9 lots of years I was on
the radio it was ten percent when I
started this show it was ten percent and
so then it came down to six and we
thought we were in China but then when
it goes to three and it goes up to seven
see seven is not good as compared to
three but it's really good compared to
twelve so it's an emotional thing so
here's what I'm telling you the other
article we got was from Bloomberg it
talks about the people that have bought
homes their values are continuing to go
up especially if you bought like in
Austin Texas you know Nashville
Tennessee you bought in these are Dallas
Texas you're buying the Phoenix Arizona
you know they've gone down a little bit
in some of those areas in the last four
or five months yeah a little boy asking
prices too and the price asking yeah
because some of them had really gone
crazy up and so it's settling it's
settling but it's not diving it's not
crashing and what's happening is these
people that bought
are going to become inordinately more
wealthy over the next three years than
people who rented
because rents are also going through the
roof
and so rents are sucking the disposable
income out of the renter's budget
where when you buy because guess what
happens to rents every year they go up
just about
almost every single year rents go up
when you buy a house at six percent or
seven percent
it doesn't go up you're locking in
you're one of your largest expenses and
the value of the property is going up
because it's not crashing
unless you're in one of those areas we
mentioned right it's not crashing
overall we don't have a 2008 situation
and you're going to become wealth
inequality
based on home ownership is going to be
more and more of a thing and so what all
that is to say is if you haven't bought
a house and you're thinking about buying
a house and you're sitting on the
sidelines waiting on interest rates to
come down they're not going to come down
in any minute and waiting on house
prices to come down they're not going to
come down they're going to go up
you need to go buy a freaking house
right now it's a great time to buy a
house because there's not a lot of
people around the block trying to buy
that house right this second you're not
going to steal it
and if you're getting ready to sell a
house you need to have the expectation
it's going to take you 90 days to sell a
house right now like it has most of the
time in the history of Real Estate
most the time in the history of real
estate that's how it's gone
and and so you need to have a 90-day
expectation on selling and negotiating
on your price that's normal and if
you're thinking about buying you ought
to go buy right now and like we said a
real estate reality check you can always
refi later when the rates come back down
yeah if they come back down to three and
they might sure hope they do they'll be
wonderful and refinance and get rid of
that higher mortgage but you locked in
the price of the house